the EU says it's preparing new economic
sanctions against Russia in response to
its announced military mobilization and
the preparation of so-called referendums
in Ukrainian territory a foreign affairs
Chief Joseph borrowed for the EU said
the measures would focus on individuals
as well as certain sectors of the
economy they would be the eighth package
of sanctions against Russia Boral was
speaking in New York after a meeting of
EU foreign ministers on the sidelines of
the U.N General Assembly
and for more on this we welcome Oleg
ustenko to the show he's an economic
advisor to Vladimir zielinski president
of Ukraine uh Mr ostenko thank you for
joining us here terrific I want to begin
with these sanctions or this discussion
of new sanctions with this escalation
that we're seeing from Putin in terms of
his language in terms of the
mobilization can we expect do you expect
that to sharpen EU resolve for sanctions
or do you expect to see a let up as we
near winter and colder temperatures uh
look now I think that it's very clear
for everybody the war now which Russia
and his regime uh the Putin's regime is
conducting against us is not just our
war it's war against all of us it's war
against Europe and it's also war against
the Civilized World from this point of
view of course we have to understand
that our militaries are doing the best
they can do on a battlefield but the
reason now that Battlefield and this
another Battlefield is everything
related to sanctions and from this point
of view what we would expect after those
steps which were undertaken by Moscow
quite recently we are expecting more
sanctions and more precisely to tell
about sanctions I would say that we are
expecting sanctions which will really
hit Russia in terms of their uh
Financial revenues
we have to stop sending bloody money uh
to Vladimir Putin and his regime which
means for me that we have to stop
everything related to trading with
Russia in terms of energy so energy
sanctions this is what is desirable and
what we would love to see in package
number eight this is really needed and
please keep in mind that Russians are
receiving the main source of their
revenue from energy sector it's more
than 40 percent just from oil they are
receiving between 35 to
37 let's say up to 40 just from oil
that's why it's all very important the
EU could say look we've agreed to end
Imports of coal which it's already put
in place we've agreed to end oil imports
later this year and that natural gas is
no longer as much of an issue because
Russia itself is already reducing flows
what more can you expect if the EU can
point to those things and say and say
we've already taken steps right the
steps are already taken and yes it's
true that embargo the oil embarga is
going to be imposed since uh December
5th it's also true that we are working
on a so-called price mechanism or price
cap for Russian oil but in fact it's
going to be imposed my understanding is
also since December 5th this is
definitely not enough please please keep
in mind that every day Russians are
receiving from their energy somewhere
close to 1 billion euros 1 billion Euro
and the war they are conducting against
all of us caught them for their budget
approximately around 750 million euros
meaning that we have to cut off them
from there but let me also tell you that
when you're talking about the coil coal
industry yes it was already imposed in
Varga but as we can see just recently
there was kind of some flexibility which
EU already showed in you changing its
guidelines exactly exactly this is not
just acceptable look our people are
still just to clarify real quick that
you changed its guidelines to allow EU
shippers to ship Russian coal to third
parties that originally was not part of
the sanctions but that was changed
recently the EU saying that it's
necessary for Global Security I'm sorry
go ahead yes and we think that it's just
not acceptable just not acceptable so so
basically the position is not that
strong as is supposed to be in terms of
guess it's also true yes you are
absolutely right Europe is less
dependent now on Russian oil and Russian
gas but also true that never never ever
never
again Russia is going to be a reliable
so we have to prepare Europe now now
Europe have to be prepared for those
non-reliable uh energy sources now so it
means that the steps should be
undertaken now despite at the same time
Europe is about to enter winter
temperatures are already colder here
many businesses and households are
switching from gas fueled heaters to
fuel oil heaters so if there's suddenly
a uh an embargo on oil tomorrow
potentially prices go up they're facing
higher prices how do you respond to that
message when people tell you and I'm
sure you've been hearing this we're not
ready to sacrifice our comfort or or
it's just not sustainable price wise
that is a legitimate concern here how do
you how do you address that I would say
that first of all when we are talking
about oil prices it's just not the case
when we are introducing this price cap
it's very likely that it's going to be
even not sure
look we heard a lot of talks all over
Europe and in the world in terms of if
you are going to impose you know
anything uh any embargo related to
Russian oil then the prices are going up
just dramatically rocket sky but it did
not happen and look what are the prices
for energy now they're on a level let's
say of around 100 dollars per barrel for
brand and even now when sanctions are
not still in place for energy sector we
can we can we can observe that Russians
are trading with their oil with a
significant discount so but it's also
true that now in Europe you have enough
uh storages to go through this winter in
terms of gas in terms of oil in terms of
all other energy resources on the top of
that please also keep in mind that if
here if here you are talking about one
two Celsius below compared with what you
had before in your apartments please
also think about our people who are
living without hitting at all you know
at all I want to switch gears for a
second and ask you in a month there's
going to be a major donors conference
here in Berlin for Ukraine
um how important is it to convince
potential donors and creditors that
Ukraine continue to have military
success how couple how closely coupled
is that with your appeal for more money
frankly uh let me be as Frank as
possible here look we have to understand
that when the economy the Ukrainian
economy was destroyed and is still
destroying it because it's still under
attacks of Russian of course our budget
is not experienced the best time
initially we were planning that it's
going to be a budget deficit for whole
year 7.5 billion euros now we have this
monthly deficit of around 5 billion
euros the monthly deficit obviously we
need to continue our economic uh to be
running so this is for sure because
again we have two different fronts we
have one front which is an actual
Battlefield another front which we have
is an economic front you're printing
more money right now how long is that
sustainable I'm not talking about that
I'm asking for more money I am asking
that you know EU have to deliver what
was promised before and we are coming to
the New Year meaning that we still are
going to have a budget deficit our
economy is doing a little bit better now
compared with the first months of the
invasion but still we are expecting that
it's going to be a budget deficit on a
level of 40 billion euros next year and
it means that if you would like to win
this war and I am sure that we need to
uh to be in this war moreover we need to
win this war as soon as possible right
we it should be finished as soon as
possible then we have you know several
simple requests we need more weapons and
we need more ammunition we need money to
finance our budget deficit because we
need to pay salary go into that you are
in discussions right now with the IMF
about what you want from them you want
to specifically especially tailored
program to the tune of 15 to 20 billion
euros for Ukraine from the IMF that you
also believe will help stabilize
finances bring in more support uh
there's been some hesitancy from the IMF
to support aside in a war essentially to
to potentially throw its weight in one
direction if it's not sure who's going
to even win this conflict how are those
negotiations those talks going and how
do you overcome that hesitation uh Luke
let me be very clear in our minds we
don't have even that questions who is
going to win this war it's actually not
a conflict it's a war and in our view we
are going to win and everybody
understands that we are going to win
this war and even if you can look at our
latest development on the battlefield
it's also very sure that we are winning
this war and also true that we need to
keep an Integrity a Unity
among our among our allies and it's also
true that we are in consultations and
even I would say that in technical
consultations now with IMF how's that
going what are you hearing from their
side you feel optimistic about it and
they are very optimistic about that side
the uh the negotiations are going the
Prime Minister already made several
statements related to this issue we are
expecting the mission of IMF so we are
moving forward there but it's also true
that you know finance and current needs
are extremely important but you are
talking about the conference which is
going to take place in Berlin extremely
important just extremely important and I
would say that we have to to think in
terms of two different Horizon the one
the first one is a short-term Horizon
and this short Horizons I would call it
a fast track uh program Fast Track
recovery program this is you know the
Ukrainian way how we call it in Ukraine
look we have hundreds of thousands
people who uh who just do not have uh
roofs above them as winter approaches
and winter is approaching exactly then
we have critical infrastructure uh
destroyed some critical infrastructure
needs to be repaired right the Russians
have destroyed some power plants as
they've been moving out of these areas
absolutely but then of course the second
part of the discount person is
everything related to rebuilding of
Ukraine but the war is still going
that's why actually the sooner we are
finishing this world the sooner we got
our common Victory the better we are
going to be in the future and less money
actually we are going into a 50 billion
dollar price tag that's the estimate for
rebuilding right now in Ukraine almost
100 billion dollars worth of physical
damage alone I want to ask you um
finally to wrap up are you are you
optimistic or are you pessimistic as you
go around Europe and you talk to uh
Europeans about
um your needs and what you're pressing
them for
uh well in in terms of numbers
350 billion US Dollars those which are
already verified however the price tag
might be much higher and the work keep
in mind that the war is still ongoing so
the price tag if you are including the
direct and indirect cost might be as
high as 1 trillion US dollars or Euros
if you are talking in terms of attitude
of people here I would I can ensure you
that majority of Germans majority of
Europeans are in favor okay we're gonna
have to leave it there that was olag
ostenko economic advisor to Ukrainian
President Vladimir Solinski Mr rosenko
thank you very much for joining us sorry
thank you so much I appreciate your time
thank you thank you